hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the finest game of today's
showing uh from the magnus carlson
invitational knockouts it's wesley saw
versus alireza felucia wesley already
won the first two games and now alireza
has
only one chance to bounce back he needs
to win a game three end game for
just uh to end the the first day with a
draw
and wesley has the white pieces here and
this is an amazing game so i'm sure you
guys are going to enjoy it let's
check it out so wesley with the white
pieces opened with e4
and for this game alireza uh decided to
go for the carl khan we have c6
d4 uh we have d5 and now e5 wesley goes
for the advanced variation of the karo
khan
uh bishop to f5 developing the light
square bishop so you
uh you can play e6 later on and never
again have to worry about developing
your light square bishop
and knight to f3 here you can play a lot
of other moves like bishop to e2 you
could go h4
g4 has been played so a lot of very
interesting possibilities but wesley
keeps it clean
uh knight to f3 and e6 now now as
planned we have bishop to e2 and now
knight to e7 uh here black is uh
preparing moves like h
uh like h6 g5 the knight can then be
brought to g6 and so on
so here uh wesley castles and now h6 uh
alireza cannot play any sort of a safe
opening he needs to go for a win
uh otherwise it's just game over for him
with a4 wesley grabs
a bit a bit more space on the queen side
and g5 now
and there is one game in the database
where uh uh
knights the e1 was played kinda in
preparation of
black uh preparing g4 but here we have
a5 and it is already as of move eight
that we have a completely new game
so let's see how the game continues we
have a6 all it is it doesn't allow
uh obviously to push this pawn all the
way to a6
and now b4 uh just grabbing more space
here
and as you can see uh wesley really
playing some fine positional chest not
allowing all it is uh
any uh sharp uh ideas uh and it's um
a very questionable uh how are you
developing this knight because
for example after knight d7 which was
played in the game all of these squares
are covered by wesley's pawn so nothing
really
uh can be can be uh done about that but
alireza has a plan we have c3
and now f6 uh busting open the position
in the center
uh we have e captures on f6 but now not
capturing right away and allowing knight
to the e5
first knight to g6 now with both knights
covering e5
uh you are only now going to capture on
f6 probably with the queen
so here we have f7 with check uh
you have to give up this pawn so why not
give it up uh by uh preventing
black from castling because maybe black
wanted to castle queen side
and you kind of don't want that to
happen so king captures on f7 and now
knight b
to d2 probably coming to b3 then to c5
later on
so bishop to d6 and now knight to b3
as planned we have queen to c7 now
putting pressure on the h3 pawn here
and g3 but now by playing g3 yes uh
this bishop is no longer as powerful but
you gave alireza
a nice weakness to hone in on so h5 h4
is definitely coming first knight to f6
by alireza
now the knight can also jump to e4 to g4
to h5 if needed and
you know it's it's a very it could be a
very useful attacking piece
so bishop to d3 wesley of course wants
to exchange
uh some of the attackers and now uh g4
pushing back the knight we have knight
to e1 uh
knights the e5 check also possible but
it's uh
it's a very very tactical uh idea that
doesn't really do anything for white so
instead the knight back to e1
uh and here h5 now uh alison wants h4
uh h captures on g3 and he wants to
attack the white king hopefully double
up the rooks on the
uh h file well obviously not that but
maybe something like rook h7 rook 8
h8 and so on so here we have rook to a2
the rook will be very useful in helping
out with the defense of the second rank
uh and now h4 and okay wesley continues
with knight to c5 and here we have
rook to h5 and now what do you play here
uh well it's a very very tricky position
but uh
there is a move that really gives white
the advantage i'm not going to ask you
to find it because it's
such a disgusting engine line i'm just
going to show it to you
so here the best for white is f3 and
this is going into the position from the
thumbnail this was not played in the
game this is just uh
i mean complete madness because after f3
of course you want to open up the f file
as the king still occupies it on f7 and
now after h captures on g3
f captures on g4 there's this g2 move
and
who knows what's happening here and now
you have to go for
rook captures on g2 but now comes bishop
captured because once you've played
this uh g2 move not only have you
attacked the rook but now there is a
triple attack on the h2 pawn
so here this is still best rook captures
on g2 uh
bishop captures an h2 with check and now
king to f2
and now look at this position this is
actually the position from the thumbnail
this is complete madness uh white uh
white
is better here but uh i mean good luck
playing this in a
in an actual practical game with all of
these pieces
in front of the white king it's i mean
uh pretty crazy and
i guess wesley agrees because he did not
go for this uh some positions
are best left unexplored so here uh
instead after rook the h5
wesley goes rook to e2
and now puts pressure on the e6 pawn and
now comes
h captures on g3 now alireza opens up
the h file we have h
captures on g3 sorry if captures on g3
and here
bishop captures on g3 it makes sense you
want to bring the queen into the attack
you want a double rooks on the h file
and hopefully chuck made the white king
so h captures on g3
and now queen captures with check you
cannot block with the knight if you
block with the knight then rook 8 to h8
and that's just it there's no defending
this
so instead we have rook to g2 now
attacking uh alireza's queen and now
queen to h3 it's very interesting uh
you could try and offer a queen here but
it doesn't end in checkmate because
after this
rook to h1 check it the king doesn't
have to go at the g2 the king actually
has king if
uh king f2 and then after this check the
king has king e3 so
uh you know i know you guys were
thinking about sacrificing the queen but
it doesn't work
uh yet so here after rook g2 we have a
queen to
h3 and now comes knight captures on e6
grabbing that pawn and it is a peace
sacrifice but
it's gonna uh really really weaken the
the black king's defenses so here bishop
captures and now
knight to f3 and here uh there are all
sorts of uh nasty ideas in the position
uh most natural one of course if if the
pawn is captured
then you open up the attack towards this
knight here from the rook and the bishop
this comes with
check and a lot of things can go wrong
for black and
they would go wrong for black but there
is something even greater here
so feel free to pause the video and win
this position for wesley while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh
now sacrificing the queen and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures on g2 queen captures
on g2
you could also go a queen to h1 check
king to f2 and then
queen captures and g2 but that's just
prolonging the idea
so queen captures and g2 is actually
what you have to play here and this is
just beautiful
king captures now g captures on f3 with
check and you cannot capture this if you
capture with the king then bishop to g4
for example
uh wins back the queen and then black is
just up too much material
so here after this g captures on f3 with
check you have to play something else
but
there really isn't a good move here if
you try capturing with the queen
then just knife the h4 check again uh
the king and queen are forked
it's completely winning uh and uh again
not
nothing better can can be done here if
you capture with the rook it's uh the
same idea knight h for checking you you
don't want to give up
more material so here uh after this king
to g2
g captures an f3 check you would have to
play king to f2
uh and then now comes the the star move
and that of course is
rook to h2 with check and again you do
not want to capture this because of
bishop to g4
you have to continue running king to e3
but now just to rook to e8 and look at
this position this is uh this is the
immortal uh never never uh
to have occurred game uh as there is
nothing
uh uh there is nothing uh white could
have done here
uh because it's just uh i mean this is
just beautiful
uh so here uh after this position that
did not occur
if it had occurred there i mean there's
no move here the rook is completely
cutting off the
uh the white king all of the other
squares are covered
uh the the bishop is ready for some
nasty discoveries uh and
best of all if bishop captures making
room for the king here on d3
with king captures and king to d3 bishop
to f5
is checkmate so this is uh this is this
is really insane so uh yeah after this
knight to f3 by wesley sorry i i
i think i said that wesley has a winning
move alireza has a winning move
sometimes i mix the names and colors i
have no idea what it is
uh but yeah uh this is completely
crushing for alireza but he missed it
uh and he uh i guess he kind of thought
wesley was onto something here
uh so he decided to go for this knight
to h4 move
and now now wesley just trades knight
captures on h4
uh queen captures on h4 and now bishop
to f4
uh adding another defender here and also
preparing bishop to e5 which would come
with a double attack on the knight here
so rook eight to eight eight alireza now
triples up on the h file and now queen
to e2
uh we have queen to h1 with check king
to f2
and now queen back to h4 with check
wesley repeats king to g1 he says
okay i'm happy with the draw here if
there is nothing else
but alireza is not happy with the draw
as he needs a win to
uh get back into the match so it is a
push is g3
uh we have bishop captures on g3 and now
uh
now queen to h3 now giving white to the
move
but now wesley plays bishop to e5 and
now there's a problem the knight is
under attack
and while rook 8 to h6 is um
kind of defending the move alireza
played is
not so here uh after rook five to h6 uh
he we immediately have rook captures on
f6 with check
rook captures and bishop captures on f6
with check
and there's a problem here now because
if alersa grabs the bishop then queen to
e5
check and that's it king e7 rook to g7
check
and you're getting checkmated king e8 uh
bishop g6
check and that's just it king of f8
you're going to deliver a check here
bishop blocks and then queen captures
with
check so instead after bishop captures
an f6 alireza goes for queen to h1
check king to f2 and now rook to h2
uh threatening queen captures on g2 with
check
but now it's now it's actually wesley
that's winning that's probably why i
said that wesley was winning in that
position could be
so now wesley is completely winning here
but there is only one move that wins the
game
uh so for the last time pause the video
and win the game this time
truly for wesley while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
uh think of the evergreen game and that
is bishop the g6 with
check whenever i see this double bishop
king sand which i always think of the
the evergreen game i hope you guys know
and uh
have seen that one if you haven't i will
put a link to it in the description
below because it's just a
uh you know a spectacular game it's been
a while since i've done it
and then you know the quality is not as
great you know it's in 30 frames per
second and so on
but still do check it out also a nice
opportunity to see how the channel
progressed
over time so this would be completely
crushing because after
you make a move here and there is no
good move for you to make here
uh the thing is after king captures the
dark square bishop now comes queen to e5
with
check and this connects with the rook
here and that's just it that's all there
is after the king moves you're gonna
capture the rook rook captures the queen
has to move and then
rook to h7 will be crushing and there's
uh
nothing better after this bishop to g6
move if you move the king
again it's it's nothing better king f8
queen to f3 now threatening a lot of
nasty discoveries and that's it uh
black is black is down a piece so black
can't really afford any trades but you
don't have any options you you have to
trade here because the king has nowhere
to go you can't go here you can't go
here this
this is all uh taken and of course king
to f8 again goes into the line of fire
of the rook so
yeah nothing nothing to do here so after
this rook the h2 move uh this
was crushing bishop to g6 check however
wesley played rook captures on h2
uh we have queen captures an h2 with
check and now king the e1
it's like they're you know playing ping
pong with the evaluation bar
a little bit uh and now queen g3 with
check we have king to d2
and now king captures on f6 finally but
now
uh it's just um completely equal
position
both players with a queen with a light
square bishop and with four pawns so
here
queen if i serve wrong queen queen e5
check uh even offering a pawn because
wesley now knows that this is a draw and
a draw is all he needs to win the game
so queen captures with check we have d
captures king captures and now
uh black is up upon but it is not enough
we have king e3
a very nice opposition uh we have bishop
back
bishop to f5 now offering a trade and
bishop back to e2 yeah you could even
though black is up upon you can even
trade here and and get a draw
uh but uh you know wesley doesn't want
to calculate
unnecessarily so just bishop e2 uh we
bishop to e4 and now
bishop to g4 bishop f5 bishop goes back
bishop to f3 with bishop to e6 and now
bishop back to g2
bishop to g4 and bishop to h1 and it was
in this position on mo46 that uh
wesley and alireza agreed to a draw uh
as there is nothing more to be done here
so really a crazy game and there were so
many
winning opportunities uh for both of
them and you know uh
that those two for alies especially that
one with the queen sacrifice
it was simply amazing uh but it's a
rapid chess you know uh
you know brilliant positions will occur
but uh of course the players will not be
able to always find
all the ideas uh and here even wesley
okay wesley wasn't really
maybe even uh trying that hard to win
the game because he only needed a draw
to win the
the first day uh of the of the
tournament but
um yeah it was definitely in the
position and had he found that
bishop to g6 check uh it would be a very
very swift victory so really a crazy
crazy game hope you guys enjoyed it as i
definitely think this is my favorite i
haven't seen all of them
from day one but it's hard that any of
them would would stop this one
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it wesley wins the first
day
uh i would like to thank loca stel caris
dale lear vessel in velichkov uh cheese
roast and paul hunter for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon uh continuing
the coverage of this very nice
tournament uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day